this next story ties in exactly what you
were just saying about these leftists
saying you've got the resources just
give them to me
not realizing all the work that goes
into it so the big news we have now that
came out today
is that mitch mcconnell first of all he
he objected to the two thousand dollar
stimulus
bill and everybody's complaining oh
mitch mcconnell's blocking our stimulus
or whatever
mitch mcconnell introduces two thousand
dollar aid checks bill
tied to social media immunity and
election fraud
this is really interesting stuff
basically what mitch mcconnell is saying
is i'm not gonna give you your blanket
two thousand dollars
you're gonna vote for my two thousand
dollars and here's what it says as part
of mcconnell's bill
section 230 the social media immunity
law would be repealed
and a commission on election fraud would
be created the stimulus checks would be
increased to two thousand dollars from
the current six hundred
quote it will not pass the house and
cannot become law
senate democratic leader chuck schumer
said in a statement referring to the
democratic majority house of
representatives
mcconnell's office was not immediately
available for comment blah blah blah
do you think they're going to vote for
this because this is interesting stuff
i've been saying for a while you know
trump wants to repeal 230
i think it's really really bad but some
conservatives made some really good
points and i'll tell you why i think
it's bad
repealing 230 means that it's
it's the end of social media as we know
it i think
if i was going to be optimistic this
show would probably be fine
because youtube is trying to be like
netflix
and they like this show you know they
they they seem to like me and
the people i associate with or whatever
because you know it's safe i suppose
well youtube doesn't even have a problem
with you being on the show right
so here's the point if i was gonna like
pitch something to netflix
you know i've actually had a lot of
discussions it's likely they'd probably
pick something up
so youtube's going to be like this is a
good show we can keep this work safe but
they're going to get rid of all the
smaller creators
your channel eric might be at risk
because they're going to be like we
don't know this guy is we don't care
and we don't want to get sued for libel
and defamation so they're going to get
rid of anyone who's not approved
so i think ultimately it's a bad bad
idea but what's interesting is a lot of
conservatives brought a really good
point
they said tim we've already been purged
it's only good for us
if they get rid of it if we're out then
so like
so i guess the way you put it is if
right now the media companies are
favoring progressive ideals and
restricting conservatives
then the best thing for conservatives is
to nuke the whole system because right
now they're losing because of it
well i think section 230 is going to be
abused especially
under a biden administration that has
many high level
tech executives within it and of course
they're going to be padding and
patting each other on the back and
helping each other out and of course the
little guys are going to get screwed
over and everyone else is going to be
allowed to do what they usually do or
it's just not going to be enforced like
many of the laws that are just there
on the books but they're not really used
at all so i think that's
a probability that we have to understand
here as well i don't know if that
actually moved to repeal it but i know
that democrats are probably going
oh no oh i can't believe they're going
to repeal this
whatever will be due because like i said
youtube will allow my show to be around
and you know what else is going to
happen take a look at netflix take a
look at all these big production
you know companies what kind of movies
are they making they're making woke
and far left and weird whatever yeah
they're making all of this stuff
so if you get rid of the independent
creators that's what's left
yeah with their competition though like
i've
long talked about that like we are this
is why channels like mine
uh blew up over the course of the last
you know couple of years
because of that it's like a lot of folks
are tired of that they're like all right
we're being lectured all the time in the
movies that we
watch the games that we play the comic
books that we read
and and and we don't want any of that
but the issue though
is when we talk about like i don't know
these
uber like tech companies that that take
these government
i would encourage you guys to look at
that i know we talk about corporate
welfare all the time but
just go look at how much these guys get
in terms of um
not even with the taxation but just with
like how they work with the government
directly be it in government contracts
like this big tech company yeah
yeah exactly and why it is that they
often
favor uh those more regulatory bodies
because they're the ones that benefited
we talk about we talked about that last
show
with um i talked about the bail monopoly
like that was
what what happened they work with the
state and then it sounds good it's like
hey we're protecting you
net neutrality we're protecting you and
then it's like no it
actually does not benefit you they just
worded it in their way this is supposed
to benefit you that's how the game works
mitch mcconnell is is coming at
repealing 230 and an election
an election fraud investigation from the
left
the left argument this is really
interesting give the people their two
thousand dollars and uh repeal 230.
that's that's how they do it and
although they give you money
now i think that you know part of me i
look at the repeal of 230
and like imagine if we got rid of social
media we went back to the era of like
four or five news channels
then you'd have the restoration of many
news organizations
and a balance of competition between
perspectives and a more unified world
view
and with for people in this country at
least that's the idealistic utopian
vision of what might happen in reality
what will happen is the progressive
leftists who have already gone insane
from their own platforms like jack
dorsey went nuts
jack dorsey's own creation twitter made
him crazy
and i i mean it you can look at the
things he believes and says
and it's a product of the far left in a
in a in
a swimming in a pool of their own filth
yeah and then
they prop each other up the likes create
more likes create more shares more
retweets and then it spirals out of
control and he starts believing
you know the refuge coming out of his
own platform that will be what's left
there won't be this perfect system of
restoring balance and bringing back
regular and honest independent voices
nope it's
too late there's a split if they get i
tell you this man if they get rid of 230
and it really does result in more
censorship and more banning it would
just accelerate everything
i think though when we talk about that
and also the other pork though
you know that we somehow stopped talking
about pakistani gender studies yes
all of that stuff that's another way in
in how they
pass stuff like that you're seeing an
example of that it's like
how can we get them to focus on that
like okay even all right
they want a little more cash bound a
little more cash and then it's like all
right well we'll give them 2 000.
but all of that garbage is still in
there yeah right it's still there and
we're not uh i don't want to say we're
not talking about it but it's like oh
hey we're getting we're getting a raise
on
on this free money that we just printed
out in there uh uh
but we're not talking about that's how
it gets passed it's like if i can get
you to focus on that they do that with
titles of bills all the time where it's
like
hey this is supposed to be this and then
someone that actually reads the damn
bills like wait a minute that's not what
that is rand or some
something like that's not what that is i
actually read this bill it doesn't
say do exactly this this and that and
then they're like well
he's a racist because he didn't vote for
for this
the the you like black people bill or
something like that and there's all
types of garbage in it
yeah if they took the entire omnibus
and just broke it up and spread it
around no no no no no i mean it's broken
up and said
we're going to give everyone an equal
share every american every working
american you're talking about like
in the price point eddie said right now
2.7 trillion or whatever divided by 225
million working americans everybody gets
like 12 grand
12 grand another thing we need to
realize we need to stop
saying that the government is giving us
something they're not they're
borrowing it from us which we're going
to have to pay back
taxes or with inflation for us or our
children or our children children are
going to have to
pay for this guarantee still they're
stealing from future generations and
this is why we
that's why they're not giving us nothing
yeah yeah it's the the value what you
have right now and
they're selling off assets of unborn
people that's exactly what they're doing
and the fact that people are just so
okay with that to me is what's so freaky
about it you break it down to them like
dude
that money is not there this whole myth
that you think well i'm just getting my
taxpayer money back your money's gone
they don't have it they don't they don't
have it they're they're in the red
right now and still spending it they
don't have yours we got off the gold
standard
because they borrowed your money spent
it and when you asked for it bet it said
here's a piece of paper
it's good for the money exactly people
are like all right i guess
i don't think you can go back on the
gold stand at this point a lot of people
wanted to was it
didn't trump try appointing that lady
who wanted to get down the gold standard
i wish that would have happened
that would have been so hard yeah you
know i just kind of want
like i don't know if i think the system
might be too far gone but it would be
nice to be back on a track where you can
understand what's happening
and we're at this point now where it's
this massive ponzi scheme
where they just deficit spend into
oblivion which results in
like the interest being higher than the
ability to even pay anything back
so that means there's rapid inflation
it's a big ponzi scheme
and they and the reason it won't
collapse because they have guns if
donald trump was real he would have
appointed ron paul to the head of the
federal reserve
i talked to rod
if they really wanted to take an axe to
the system that would have been the guy
that they went with in 2012 to 2008 as
well
but no like he told me he would do it
yeah of course i know it will but
seriously guys it's like
trying to get people to it's like
pulling literally pulling teeth
out of people uh people's mouths man
trying to get them to understand
that money's not there it's like they
don't they don't get it i'm getting
these fights with
with uh can i say boomer conservative is
that is that like
offensive or something like that okay
all right so you can say i'm kidding
all right yeah probably i'm kidding yeah
but um no and i talk about social
security
and they like seriously think well if
we're gonna take away social security
then i want my money back and i'm like
bro
your money's not there the money that
you that you were
you were being taxed you've been stolen
from which is the decent portion of your
check
is gone they don't even pretend that it
is yours what's happening right now
is you're living off of the current
generation that's going to end up in the
same position why it's a
it's a literal ponzi scheme uh in that
regard but people don't understand that
and i guess it's because maybe the state
has baby them and giving them whatever
they want check this out so so
uh you know luke and i were talking
about getting this big farm property and
what we could do if we had like our own
cryptocurrency
and it's like we want people to come and
and contribute and help us build stuff
and i'm like how do you actually create
value in a currency how do you actually
convince people it's worth something
if you can just print it out of thin air
why would anyone be like oh i want some
of that
why you're just gonna keep printing for
the background we were talking about
creating two kind of civilizations no
that one with a lot of
government one with no government and
we're gonna think of ways
how to make currencies we're talking
about cryptocurrencies and using some
kind of way to create
value one idea i had was to make one
working hour
a value token that people could use and
trade within the community
that's what some local communities and
breaking ridges listen
but the problem is so first the context
is like
doing some kind of show where we're like
who would succeed regulation versus no
regulation
and the problem with that idea of the
hour is if someone can just print the
money
arbitrarily then why would i do work for
your currency if you're
not working and just printing it out and
getting whatever you want from me that's
what's happening right now i know
you just described american fiscal
policy good job right but that's
that's why i complain to people when
they're like just print more when rand
paul comes out and he's like why not
twenty thousand
why not ubi and i'm like yes
people don't get it no you can't just do
that that's true
but no it's happening but that's why and
it's funny you guys are having that
conversation though that's exactly
why it's important that the market be
free enough for folks that are even
smarter than everybody that's at the
table right now
to be able to figure that out and answer
that sort of question this is why people
acting freely is so
important because we don't got our
answers it's actually these very very
arrogant
uh it's not just progressives but you
know it's it's especially progressives
that are very arrogant enough to think
that they have the all the answers and
because they can't it's one of the
biggest criticisms of
what maybe luke and i more so believe in
is that well they figure well i can't
i can't possibly like conceive an idea
or see that world actually coming to
fruition and i'm like
how arrogant of you to think you're the
smartest person to ever live that just
because you can't see that being done
it just can't be done at all you know
and it's kind of funny sorry ian going
oh yeah what we could do in a community
is we each print our own crypto
and then so if you wanted me to do
something for you
it would be five tokens you would give
me five tokens or i would give you five
tokens for your product
but if i gave you if i paid you an error
coin i only had to give you four tokens
so the value then would it would create
a value
system for all these different
currencies that we'd start inter trading
like i would give you
five tokens for four if you're gonna
give me eric tokens so that we we
still make a we still come out even
except you get an extra token out of it
so and then you're gonna you're gonna
still get tokens for your
labor and get paid um and then they
could pay you five tokens of else
uh i think that would that would be how
you would do see that this con
and i think that i love we have in this
conversation because these are the
conversation that
innovators have right and these are
these are these are and this is why it's
so important
for the market to be free enough so we
can have that conversation the state
says
well i have the smartest people on my
team
therefore what i say has to go never
mind if it hasn't worked
never mind it's it's the possibly the
most dumbest idea it doesn't matter i
have the monopoly on law
well this is the important thing when
we're moving towards an ideology
we're moving away towards a merit-based
society and whenever we see governments
whether germany and world war ii
or the ussr before world war one
whenever they
push ideology more than they do merit
there's always a lot of destruction
because there's always a controlling of
individuals not based
on their intelligence not based on their
skills but based on their obedience to
the state
and it's interesting that they call
themselves you know individuals call
themselves progressives
when in human history you look at
innovation progression
it's made when there's very little
government absolutely and then these
individuals who want more government
are calling themselves progressives like
that that to me is just
mind-boggling it's it's it just shows
you that we're kind of living in a 1984
double speak world where
words have double meanings now the left
uh i think it was jenk yuger who said
this the the progressives always win
that the left always wins
and my people corrected him saying no
liberty always wins a lot of these
issues people talk about going back to
like
the fight for freedom of speech in the
vietnam era was about liberty
individual rights civil rights gay
marriage all the stuff has always
has always been about individual
liberties absolutely and the rights of
the individual to do things
it's not been about your authority as
governor of new york
to shut down the economy destroy
people's lives and put up checkpoints
around your city
to make sure nobody comes in and that
almost sounds like you're just
separating yourself from the rest of
this country we talked about divorce
before
a lot of these places already doing it
but here's here's i want to move on to
this this subject
of what happens when people finally have
had enough because we did mention this a
little bit earlier in the show
what happens when people have nothing
left to lose what happens when we start
seeing more and more videos of people
who are desperate
we see these these stories about the
woman beating the cop with the with the
baton because you don't want to
wear a mask people are angry and they
don't care if you know
you guys you guys ever hear that story
about the dude who walks into a bank
and has a note the note is a is a
robbery
he's demanding one dollar he threatens
him and says give me a dollar or else
then he goes and sits down and he waits
for the cops to come and arrest him you
know why
because he had cancer and he was going
to die and he said it's the only way i
can get treatment
that's that's why he did it the left
likes to bring it up saying that's how
messed up our health care system is
i'm like i don't think that's a good
example of how much of our healthcare
system is but i do think it's
interesting that our prisoners get
better healthcare than say like this old
guy
so there's an interesting point but this
dude was desperate so desperate he did a
staged kind of robbery to go to prison
what happens when people have nothing
left to lose and they don't care about
prison
yeah no that's when the violence happens
right when people are down and out and
i think a lot of people have taken uh
for for granted that
stability i know a lot of folks even
especially progressives talk about
change and hope and stuff like that
believe it or not a lot of people don't
want that
right a lot of people are comfortable
being able to see exactly where they're
at
and where they're going to be able to go
it's when you get that sort of
unfamiliarity where people are like
i don't know when the next check's going
to come i don't know when
if i'm going to be able to pay
and then that's when they start to erupt
well here here's the news
ex pence aide turned trump critic very
concerned about january 6th
violence so this hotel hotel harrington
announces they're shutting down for
three days when this dc event is
supposed to happen
and apparently it's because the
washington post claimed the proud boys
were using it as
a headquarters the proud boys apparently
came out and said that's not true we
haven't used that place for months
and they're saying now on january 6
proud boys are going to be showing up in
plain clothes
not wearing their iconic shirts and some
of them
are going to be dressed like antifa so
there's a very serious concern
that there's actual planning going into
what's gonna happen
i think one of the biggest mistakes you
know i was thinking about this one of
the biggest mistakes proud boys could
make is going and fighting with antifa
right now i think that matters i don't
think trump supporters
fights are with antifa it's with the
establishment government and the
democrats
antifa's biggest mistake would be going
and fighting with trump supporters
you know it's a really interesting thing
when i see there was a funny post by
shuon head you know shu
yeah she posted uh people i think it was
in uh a camera which state it was
do you know where this was where they
were setting up the guillotine in front
of the politician's house or whatever i
think that was in mexico
yes in mexico i think and she said cons
this could be us marching to congress
together or whatever
and i said when when trump's out of the
white house the enemy of my enemy is my
friend that's going to start looking
real good to a lot of people
yeah i mean i get that my my thing is
though and why i know
a lot of folks rag on me because i say i
will not out loud with these types
because i know
my next is my my back against the wall
yeah you know what i mean and they're
going to put me up against it because
ultimately it's about
that's why i don't want to have them
using me as my useful idiots but
we got to talk about that though because
it's a legitimate concern but i also
think it's a lot of
leftists over this course of this last
year
have been trying to for the sake of
legitimizing their own bad behavior
trying to say that the other side would
do what it is that they would do now
keep in mind what all they've been doing
for the past i don't know months
right definitely this year of course
maybe we can talk about what's happened
before that but let's just focus on what
happened post george floyd
where you're talking about hundreds of
spots
and and in some cases where you go in
like the portlands and the seattles of
the world
you're talking about months at a time
right that they were just at riding
acting up so the reason why they do that
is so they can say hey
look at them and what they do right look
at look at them when
to basically to try to absolve them of
the bad behavior i think it's
likely more likely let's say don't say
likely but i think it's more likely
that they would have that you probably
see a first big pow-wow
with guys that are quote-unquote on the
right but more so with the police
because they're they're more dir when
they protest this is why you don't see
when
you generally they go do their thing you
don't really go see uh
wendy's get burnt down or something like
that generally when the
when the quote-unquote right links up
that generally does doesn't really
happen they're more precise
with what it is they do so i get the
desperation but that desperation
may have them more so turning on the and
maybe i'm just being a
an audio log right now but that
desperation may have them actually
looking to
the people who the the police more than
right right i don't i don't think trump
supporters
they're planning on going to dc setting
up tents occupying and
and protesting shutting things down i
think it's going to get pretty big i
mean you got this guy going on msnbc
saying
you know it's going to get violent and
i'm really worried about this hotel
shutting down man that's that's a crazy
signal
but what do you think's going to happen
you think antifa are going to be the
ones blocking the trump supporters from
having their protests
it's going to be the police yeah exactly
you think trump supports going to be
like okay officer we're not going to
protest
the president they've done that for a
while and and they know
that that's not work but listen listen
when trump was tweeting anti for bad
and the cops were fighting antifa they
had the trump supporters the proud boys
everybody at their back
saying do it we got your back now the
people blocking the trump supporters are
the cops and the cops saying get out of
my way
i'm here for trump not for you yeah so
i'm curious
could you know i i wonder how likely the
possibility is that you get the cops
fighting two different groups on two
different fronts
that's interesting it'll be really
different but but i i wouldn't be
surprised could have already seen right
wing groups fighting with cops
not nearly as bad as how the left does
it but it but
that was unheard of though that's why
it's important to notate that because
that's like
not a thing even back when the the tea
party thing was going down like it
wasn't
you may had a skirmish here and there
but for the most part that was not what
happened
could you imagine if there's like a guy
with a trump flag and he's yelling at a
cop and there's an auntie of a guy 10
feet away
and be a nice folk whoever gets that
photo is going to be a millionaire but
they're both failing at cops and the
antifa guy looks over and sees trump's
reporter yelling at the cop
and then he's like i'm not going to get
involved in that he keeps like i'm going
to ignore that he's not going to
normally the intimate guys want to go
fight the proud boys the proud boys want
to go fight antifa
but what happens when they're both
protesting the government
it's going to be interesting because i
think one of the problems is tribalism
and both sides are trying to use any
ally to get control of the white house
the problem is
for the left you see donald trump the
the establishment republicans
don't like him but they'll wait they'll
stand there and say okay fine well
trump's in charge will bide our time
trump supporters just want trump so that
creates a good
a good bit of unity between republicans
willing to just say okay to trump and
trump supporters who are fighting for
trump
on the left the antifa people are like
yeah yeah we'll fight with you to get
rid of trump but we're not supporting
biden yeah there's no unity on the left
over who their candidate is
so they're in a weakened position yeah
so if the if the fight is against joe
biden
and trump's gone then antiva's not going
to be fighting with the right they're
going to be fighting the cops
yeah and then the trump supporters
aren't going to be fighting with
antivirus because they're both fighting
the establishment and that's the
interesting thing like
i i don't know if that's going to be a
thing that's going to happen
because i i felt like i saw too many
times where
they kind of throughout during the obama
presidency i don't know if they've
gotten amped up enough to maybe go back
on that but during the obama presidency
there were a lot of instances in which
they could have went that route
and they decided not to in fact when it
came to the rioting that was one of the
things that obama
um certainly was he had no issue coming
out and being like
okay y'all y'all need to stop when the
ferguson thing and all that stuff
went down he was he had no issue being
like okay y'all are being
y'all are being stupid people need to
remember occupy wall street
started yeah exactly obama exactly major
riots across the united states
started under obama today i sent out a
meme
with a young girl with a biden hat
saying thank you for saving us
and then biden is there looking at her
in disgust saying
i'm literally going to do everything
trump did that's all you said
yeah and and we have to understand biden
is the epitome of the establishment when
you look at his cabinet when you look at
his administration
he has goldman sachs he has large tech
executives he has executives from all
the worst possible elements of the
corporatist
world possible people are going to get a
very rude awakening to who he really is
the policies he sets forward and when he
gets into office he's not going to serve
you
he's going to serve the special
interests that put him in there
and when he does that especially with
all the civil unrest we've been seeing
it's been brewing it's been building up
i think it would be naive to think that
there's going to be peace
civilly in the united states coming
forward from here oh yeah this is why
this is why the democrats rely on low
information voters
it's why they want the voting age to be
16 because these people who are in their
20s who voted for biden
aren't old enough to remember joe biden
killing kids
in foreign countries and obama's extra
judicial assassinations
dumb people are also let's be honest
here more violent
so when you have a whole bunch of dumb
violence people get angry
you're you're you're brewing a recipe
for disaster yeah no they were there
useful idiots i mean we saw that
with black lives matter not getting a
seat at the table like their little
civil rights uh
it's more of the civil like the
establishment civil rights guys that
were linking up with
with biden and black lives matter didn't
get a seat at the table and they were
all frustrated like
we demand a seat and i was like like
dude they've been using y'all for useful
idiots for the last i don't know
how how long it's not like they care
that y'all not understand much of what
y'all y'all i didn't get much you gotta
get anything out of pardon pres
excuse me out of an obama presidency
what makes you think that you will be
prioritized
uh they may campaign on that but what
makes you think they're going to
prioritize you
uh once they get in thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back
to check us out when we go live don't
forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you